hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2015 it's
Monday here are you ready for girl would
you ready to go work
Kevin we know about yeah of girl would
and Ubisoft conferences on in just under
15 minutes and we're here to talk about
what we expect to see in their press
conference which will last about an hour
and a half or so what an hour we'll see
we'll see how long cause an x-ray Korea
are you excited for what Ubisoft have to
show but you gay they got a bunch of
franchises most of which we've been
seeing a lot of over the past couple of
years yeah it's been no Sasson screed
far cry just stance stuff like that I'm
hoping we see a new IP that's what I'm
crossing my fingers for and let's talk
about new IPs actually right off the bat
because we kind of know what we're
talking about relation to everything
else there is this sort of a new wave in
Ubisoft to creating these rather
interesting small indie games and grow
home right valiant hearts right my child
of life Kevin would you like to see more
of that stuff you reckon we'll we'll see
a couple more of them of course who
wouldn't like to see more things like
child of light and the swarm line and
things like that I just don't know what
any of that's gonna be mmm that's the
thing I mean I'd love to see something
like more Rayman or something but I
don't think that's really on the I don't
know I don't suspect that's really on
the slate for today right
but I mean any anything coming from
there you know smaller smaller teams is
always always good Sally a especially
really the home of Rayman Beyond Good
and Evil
um valiant hearts so Misha I'm saying
yet miss Michel Ancel is no longer take
all videos he projects so you basalt yes
but if he actually really he's focusing
on wild yeah and I just say this war of
mine
I meant valiant nor execute Lear so
don't let me make a mistake like that
again another commenter skewer me
throwing event you know I've never hear
the end of that like serving you oh yeah
so talking about that I guess with his
departure or his lack of connection and
Beyond Good and Evil to if we were ever
gonna see it I know it's like a broken
record
but do you think we're gonna see
something if we don't see it this how do
we say this every year but really if we
don't see it this year it's like it's
done right I have this feeling in my gut
that it's just gone
we've there's even the rumors people
asking like no one's really talking
about it and when someone's keeping
something a secret like with I'm hate to
invoke the Last Guardian now yeah but
what stuff like that you sort of people
murmur and stories come out and there's
this constant murmur trained with it and
we haven't really gotten that with
beyond good and evil beyond good and
evil too so I think it's dead radio
silence speaks volumes a silence instead
ah Kevin Bernard
I even nice tattoo on your arm I do I do
have a nice tattoo on my roll you
excited for Assassin's Creed syndicate I
don't know uh I mean I like Assassin's
Creed you know that's why I have the
tattoo on my arm among other reasons but
you know even even I've gotten a little
you know things have got a little
wishy-washy for me over the when when
did you fall off the the curve I think
that I finished Assassin's Creed 4 and I
was like you know what I think this is
the ends of assess like I loved
Assassin's Creed 4 and I was like I
think I'm done now I think this is I
think this is reached where I needed it
to go and so unity I didn't even finish
yeah I didn't even really touch rogue at
all don't like Irish people you know
they go bad oh and then I played and
then I played chronicles China yes I
actually reviewed that and I was like
calm this could have been something and
then it wasn't
hmm so I just I I I want very much to
like syndicate I like this kind of
setting
I like the way the game looks even
though the the weird ambient lighting
they've got drives me to insane every
time we see it but we'll see I guess I'm
cautiously optimistic about Assassin's
Creed and Lucy as a northern transplant
living in the fair city boy are you
excited I'll see her your your my
stomping ground adopted home yeah no
idea yeah especially because I'm
currently living near Crawley yeah which
is where the protagonist from so I'm
kind of interested to see how that all
fits in but no I mean it's just
something it it's where I've wanted
Assassin's Creed to go for years
I've been saying you know Victorian and
Victorian London because it because
there were so many fantastic stories
from that time so you've got Jack the
Ripper you got characters characters
real people like Darwin Dickens the
royal family all that intrigue which i
think is going to be something really
fun to experiment they did but kind of
with unity but I mean obviously not
being French I might have a handle on
maybe have the characters that they had
in that game but being a being British
living in London I'm really excited this
time around the British accents on
everyone will actually make canonical
sense like it did in there and build
around Portuguese for no reason why not
um yeah that's the SS is great I guess
the engine thing about syndicate is we
haven't really seen like we've seen a
lot of it but I feel like we haven't
really seen what separates this from any
other Assassin's Creed like they talked
about how you know stealth is more of a
more of a thing we've talked about how
like the blending in with the with the
crowd acts differently it's a little bit
less I guess more contextual maybe
unless sort of rigid just trying to sort
of go down the the route that hitman did
is there anything a bit the celexa it's
like standing at you because I feel like
we haven't seen what this game has to
offer quite yet well I I went I saw
syndicate a couple months ago and their
big thing up in Ubisoft Quebec their big
thing is the syste systemic vehicle
system oh wow GTA s ability to hijack
vehicles use them to kidnap people and
run other people over with them right
you're very invested in having them
being a living breathing part of the
world that you can interact with as you
want when you want something about that
makes me laugh because the original
Assassin's Creed was this game about
spending two hours trying to you know
strategically kill one person now we're
just like mowing down pedestrians cards
I thought that was the thing in
Assassin's Creed is I don't kill
civilians you get decent credit
yeah is that still gonna be thing
doesn't really matter anymore yeah
cannon fodder has it work I guess not
let's move on from Assassin's Creed cuz
they do have a bunch of other games and
we can talk about Rainbow six siege yeah
we got a date for today October 13th at
2015 yeah and also they're giving away
Vegas 1 & 2 with this thing I guess
that's part of Xboxes new you know play
your old games Oh
on xbox one and now we can get this old
game for free yeah when they first said
it I thought they meant like Rainbow six
one yeah like Rob spear yeah Ghost Recon
I would have been a bit crazy yeah yeah
people are pumped for this I think this
has been the the beta proved to be
rather successful there's a good good
amount of sort of a positive press
around it as well and Kevin have you had
a chance to have a look go at siege or
at least I have look I played it this
year and I may or may not have plural
last year I should say I played it last
year and I may or may not have played it
this year you'll find out at in just
over an hour okay whether or not other
night is played here and whether or not
I have some things to say about really
okay so yes when you say this year you
might you might mean this week this
possibly yes absolutely it's possible I
might have played it last night even oh
really
that's where you were you know I want to
say this yeah I think probably something
tells me I have ty says it's okay yeah
something tells me all Ubisoft people
are I can't admit something else
probably Alex poetry and Tom Clancy's
the division was a massive game at e3
back in at 2013 I guess now yeah they've
been showing it off that showed a
different demo last year and this year
it's playable on the show for I am
there's a bunch of we're going to have
it on the game spots agent or I'm gonna
be playing in our roosterteeth stage at
one stage as well and any takers on the
division I know I'm very excited about
it I mean I'm excited too in part
because I sort of eyes it's sort of like
tom clancy games to begin with i like
the sort of the near-future kind of
tingle and and your big fan of the sum
of all fears yeah you mean I'm known for
that yeah that's that's my faith your
moniker every day every day then the sum
of all here's honoured but you know I
like the Tom Clancy vibe in general I
like some buff Splinter Cell you know
and and so I'm looking forward to this
because I want to see some of that vibe
come through and I kind of I kind of
want to say hey maybe this is a Tom
Clancy's destiny in a way you know not
to not to cut too many corners on what
game this reminds me of most but yeah
but I guess all that online stuff they
haven't really chewed into the details
on we've seen a lot of you know it's you
shooting stop and closing
our doors and it was the best what's
kind of interesting for this gameplay is
it I remember looking at this two years
ago be man that looks mind-blowing now
it kind of just looks like next-gen
video games yeah I'm not impressed yeah
show me something new I haven't really
seen anything let's see happen me yeah
Lucy what do you think about all that
the online stuff because obviously like
we kind of know we know what this is
some people are saying it's like oh it's
just instant spaced or maybe you have
your own group or maybe you can interact
with them or maybe doing it second
screen experience it's kind of it's
weird and it's kind of confusing
messaging as well because with a game of
this scope you want to be able to know
what exactly it is before you buy into
it so I want to know that if Kevin and I
can like buddy up and go straight into a
thing or we have to meet at a certain
place or if it's just completely random
I want to know what my multiplayer
experience is going to be like yeah I'm
going to the games at in early 2016 so I
hopefully will be finding at some
location clan all ready to go yeah I
mean we're all wearing our shirts right
now so buckle motion this are we white
and rad yeah oh no I'm different teams
want different teams you guys busy there
yeah totally will be the flame throwers
yeah whatever they're called
Sarge got fingerprints out already okay
let's go into the world of speculation
at Prince of Persia
I'd love we haven't seen that in a long
time but I'd like to see it I think
enough time has passed that it would be
acceptable and preferable to see a new
one yeah it would be the fourth time
Prince of Persia has been rebooted I
guess at this stage yeah I really hope
that movie hasn't you know ruined it for
a movie hey man if they between Prince
of Persia and hitman Hollywood is is no
shorter you mean the Hitman the first
one the new one the new one one new one
you win that trailer oh boy what do you
say rad
what do you mean but I mean you mean
like tomorrow you know yeah square thing
oh yes
true we'll be back on talking about
square tomorrow of course we're met
we're mere minutes away from Ubisoft III
2015 presentation a couple more games to
talk about Just Dance probably going to
see some Just Dance right
I predict there's gonna be some giant
stage takeover with you know a bunch of
people in colorful clothing super piping
maybe someone will have a phone like the
app thing they tried out my gosh yeah a
lot of odd I went there like a level
just you'll see Rabbids are we up on
kids game iPhone game maybe yeah maybe
mobile
I mean if minions can get a solid 5
minutes honey a stage I'm out of Pele
can get 30 minutes of his own
oh man the legend Danny that's true he
is literally God and Rocksmith maybe see
some of that I hope so because Rocksmith
great like I said this I said this
before in the lobby
the Rocksmith is genuinely a great
learning tool and while it's not
necessarily gamey
yeah any real sense popping the the
arcade stuff I'd love to see it mmm
definitely seems like a guitar czar
coming back into fashion and video games
anyway yeah yes a lot of that this year
between Dada and Tony Hawk it seems like
we've jumps back and conferences of old
yeah um how about Far Cry stuff or is a
year old your change
Ramage I don't think we'll see Far Cry 5
I just don't see it huh
well maybe not five maybe some sort of
expanded we didn't get our Blood Dragon
play right I don't know I love decane
just come right out and said there's not
gonna be a Blood Dragon - oh really
why so they could come to e3 and be like
yo there's gonna be a Blood Dragon to
snap wait then maybe they'd take us know
maybe all right I think watchdogs - oh
we know that you know that was on
someone's LinkedIn oh yeah yeah yeah
those are very much the thing that
they're gonna be working on it right
yeah they positive franchise yeah if
they say does anyone I heard a little
birdie told me a little while ago that
the setting for that is likely San
Francisco oh I'm in there that's I just
drove away from there a lot of hills
yes that's my that's my my swing for
today to see him that one hit and Aisha
Tyler's back today I like I started I
like it yeah I said the I so Tyler
I should like I should I start eisah
I used to uh it's like Lana just call
her along what's the problem
boards you keep saying it just keeps
losing own
yeah I like her I think the first year I
thought she was a little bit intense but
then I was like oh no I can't get the
skit that's yeah that's what the way it
is a good hose - yeah warm her shirt
funny as well yeah yeah she's very quick
I'm not sure he seems to care about
games yeah I'm as opposed to mr.
caffeine haha do the side by side on
what Ubisoft had and where they are now
it's kind of like they're sorry mr.
caffeine for watching I don't know I'm
sure he is offended so let's go drinking
more caffeine right now to round his
sorrows yeah he's sitting in a bar
somewhere fill me up again I'll tell you
what I'm drinking staring into the
bottom of his beer glass all day where
it all went wrong
Tommy Tom Clancy Oh God
oh you rest in peace all right let's go
around the table what's everyone looking
forward to the most
an x-ray Korea I want to see more of
Assassin's Creed syndicate
female oh yeah protagonist I want to see
more Evie yes what I'm crossing my
fingers so do a dishonored and show off
the secondary character I'd love to see
how's your other character rather yeah
we're gonna a black screen here on
Ubisoft it may be going live we've gotta
be seconds away all right we're out of
here we'll be back make sure you stay
tuned we're gonna have our own host
impressions let's see what's going on
BAM story all was cast out to sea
seemingly forgotten but now a new foe
has awakened the relic reclaimed and
what was once a powerful union lies
fractured throughout the lands
all right we'll put the stick of truth
in the toilet it's not fully ready we
agreed to get rid of the stick white
campus power again that was barely even
in our teaching house how that stuck
we're going to do it bigger and we will
settle for nothing less than a 9-5 on
James body a dark sorcerer has emerged
who is it tell us great major Santos oh
man I've no idea what's going on right
now we're under attack in the new kid is
stuck in a dream level no no dream
levels this game has to be sweet glad
show yourself villain
haha your super powers are no match for
me Putin friends Hyun in French ah [ __ ]
we got the wrong game everybody switch
games would make superheroes yeah
we're not playing games anymore man this
can it's serious
stop her the fractured but hope now
available for pre-order hey everyone
ladies and gentlemen welcome two of my
favorite human beings in the entire
world Matt Stone and Trey Parker
hi what's up are you guys doing first of
all I just like to say that these mics
are [ __ ] dumb and I feel like an
idiot wearing it don't act like you
don't wear those during sex every single
night my friend good look at you you
guys look great
come on thank you you look like you're
gonna take my order on french fries
supersize it ah yeah first of all the
trailer for game looks amazing
hey guys excited about it yeah it's
weird because you don't seem like you
are yeah and also I can't leave Mike's
it's nice to see you Mike for throwing
us but okay shall we continue with our
hands pockets or inside your pants but I
read that you guys after the last game
said that you were never ever ever gonna
make another video game again that's
true and um but uh the the big thing is
we're kind of whiny babies mm-hmm
and um we just realized that it didn't
right at the end of stick of truth we
kind of learned how to make video games
it was kind of too late yeah and we're
like well [ __ ] now we know how to make a
good video games you know we have a good
template to do it and we thought [ __ ] it
let's do it yeah yeah do it again yeah
we might regret it but we're doing it
again look I want to say knowing you too
I don't think a fear of regret has ever
kept you from doing anything
I think yet that has to be a few we've
had some regrets yeah I'm through it now
I'm you who are you working with on this
game we're working with Ubisoft San
Francisco and yeah basically yeah
obviously we've every friend the crowd
for that um it's a you know it's the
next chapter it continues the story of
stick is truth where you're the new kid
and you're in you know you now have
moved to South Park but now the kids are
playing obviously superheroes and so we
get really into your backstory is the
new kid of what like any superhero
adventure like we get into your
backstory why your butthole is so
amazing basic yeah deep into that come
on we'll deep into your butthole yeah
see if any rebuttal on this one yeah
ladies and gentlemen sweeter more the
kangaroos have never been smoked in
ladies gentlemen give it up for the
legends of South Park
thank you where those microphones home I
love you bye give it up grandma
I know ladies and gentlemen this is
ubisoft's III 200 215 that's not a year
2015
press conference if it was 215 we have
no technology we don't be incredibly
miserable staring into our hands waiting
for somebody to tweet us back
I am so insanely happy to be here today
and I don't know what you guys I feel
like this is a super special time of
year because I love games and I think
it's the rare time of year that
journalists developers gamers and fans
of the industry get to come together in
one place and collectively lose our [ __ ]
so I am so so happy to be here on behalf
of the UB team I want to welcome
everybody here to the historic Orpheum
Theatre in LA as well as all the gamers
fans and journalists tuned in online
from all over the world and we have got
a very special welcome here for some of
our most dedicated fans Ubisoft star
players who are here from around the
globe please stand and wave take your
moment in the Sun you guys look amazing
some of you look more amazing than
others
I bet the recipe which you had more than
just a [ __ ] t-shirt but that's okay
we'll talk about it like cosplay it like
a boss like a boss all right sit down
few industries have consumers as
passionate and personally invested as
the gaming industry one day you're on a
message board calling for the abrupt
non-consensual removal of a CEOs
reproductive organ on a message board
and the next thing you know you've got a
Far Cry logo tattooed on your face and
let's be honest I think we all know
there's been a very intense year for
Ubisoft and there's been no shortage of
shall we call it constructive feedback
or online teabagging whatever you want
to call it but I can say personally that
after working for these guys for four
years the Ubisoft teams listen and they
take what you think very very seriously
we believe here that passionate and
honest feedback makes games better even
if you have to dig through ear burning
NSW NSW NSFW and sfw guys that's a word
reddit thread to get it you know what
I'm talking about the ub team has a
single driving passion they love games
and they want to make kick
games that you want to play and to that
end ladies and gentlemen please welcome
the guy with all the surprises
Ubisoft CEO Yves giemo
it's good to have you back hi you know
we were in rehearsal you know how
excited I am about this press conference
you guys are gonna lose it this is gonna
be awesome
enjoy okay thank you I love gaming and I
love the people that create the games
but I also love a lot the people that
play those games so it's a
at Ubisoft we do take risks it has been
part of our DNA from day one and we will
continue to take risk to amaze gamers
and create the games of tomorrow and
today I have a surprise for you as we
said and this surprise is a new IP in a
new genre and this game couldn't wait
till the end of the show so enjoy it now
hahahaha
ah
OOP
all right when you look inside
yourselves huh do you see a knight
Viking Samurai for half Sam when your
enemies are arriving at the gates and
sword is coming at your head would you
turn and run would you stand and fight
my name is Jason Vandenberg creative
director for honor offers you the
opportunity to experience the adrenaline
and the danger of melee combat visceral
battlefield through a new type of
gameplay that we call the art of battle
you will feel the weight of the weapon
in your hand the crash as you block the
attack and the impact when you strike
the winning blow but bring your friends
with you because while a single
individual can win a fight it takes a
band of warriors to win a battle and
when I say a band of warriors
I'm a few teams of four warriors in a
live multiplayer demonstration on
console right now
who
ah
what
ah
Oh
Oh
raaah
all right thank you very much so that
was just a tease of our current bill
it's a taste of what for honor has in
store for you but I know what you're
thinking I mean that looks pretty cool
Vandenberg when can we play how about
noon tomorrow at the Ubisoft booth with
a 100% hands-on 4v4 multiplayer demo on
console
thank you very much and for those of you
watching at home go register at for
honor game.com to get more info and get
a chance to be among the very first to
play the game thank you very much and
have a great III hi
ha I was on sir guys give it a predicted
Vandenberg let hear it honor gaming team
I'm locked in the gym now I just want to
say I that was super juicy I really lost
that last paddock
these next two games are already fan
favorites and in response to the
feedback from Ubisoft's incredibly
engaged communities the teams have
created some incredibly cool expansion
packs since the crews released last year
millions of players have spent over 20
million hours free riding all across the
United States that's more than 3,000
times the distance from the earth to the
moon which by the way you cannot drive
the crew wilderun expansion pack
introduces new larger-than-life vehicles
and gives you the chance to compete in
ongoing championships called summits all
over the United States ladies and
gentlemen start your engines
yes I just get excited I want to run all
over the stage now if you think that was
awesome
this next thing is incredible I saw this
next trailer in rehearsal and I just
there are absolutely no words to
describe it so just just check it out
right insane that was just a tiny taste
of the trials fusion awesome level max
expansion pack that's coming out on the
14th of July on Xbox one ps4 and for the
PC and for any trials fusion fan it's
the business and if you are even a tiny
bit still on the fence about this but
dude you're a cat riding a
fire-breathing unicorn what are you a
robot now my friends we're going to make
a hard right turn from kitties and
unicorns to a virus ridden urban
hellscape yes we have having the same
feel at this exact same time prepare
your bodies for one of you bees most
highly anticipated games to date it's
time for the division come to the stage
ryan Barner game director on the
division give it up for Ryan
Barnard take your last name right
Barnard I realize I'm good to see you
it's my bike working all right let's go
all right hello everyone so as probably
most of you know from judging from the
response out here the division is an
online open-world action RPG but at its
core it's a cooperative experience but
today we're here to introduce you to the
dark zone a walled off quarantined
highly contaminated area all through the
middle of Manhattan and it's here where
as a player you have the choice whether
to work alongside other agents or turn
against them in the dark zone we want
you to experience the tension and the
fear and the paranoia of playing in a
place where absolutely anything can
happen at any time and place where you
can trust no one
yeah like Hollywood exactly like
Hollywood so here's a glimpse of what
could happen to you in the dark zone
area
you don't have love for on our
alright guys you ready dark zone yep
I'm just gonna mask upgrade I want to
try it out in there and get us some good
sweet let's do it
remember when we get in there it might
not be just us
transmission is jammed Rock 7 encourage
Halloween
activate sister rebooted
severely elevated beyond this point
courtly is in effect
all right behind you go ahead
life
okay go careful I see I'm not
yeah three or four breakers looks like
level 11 an assault a sniper and a
rusher should Hur I see your happy place
now yeah there's take the lead I'll
follow
yeah let's do this quickly okay cool
everybody ready
yeah see some team marking hold up
behind us six other players bastards
they have darks on booth huh
should we go for it I don't know we
can't take that man the Rikers at the
same time good point
let's just see what they do oh they're
going right guys what's up him out
alright go I'm gonna flank it go right
cover us
heads up heads up we see if I can take
him you can tear it okay it's up towards
up get down I got you I got you go go
you're [ __ ] get on the left
nice okay last one
hostiles neutralized proceed with
caution
all right Ryan you want to check out the
crate and see what these dead guys have
yeah it's do it
oh nice job nice
all right where to well let's extract at
Bryant Park that's pretty close good you
lead the way all right looks like these
other guys are coming with us
[ __ ] cleaners what's taken out that's
too risky they're all elite let's try
not to pull aggro
what do you have is five of us with
flute that we want to hold on to trust
me
follow me around this way okay right
gotcha
Brian how's it look
all right all clear let's spread out
keep a lookout guys I'm gonna call it in
okay gotcha Covered we're all clear
let's extract okay we got 90 seconds
keep your eyes peeled everyone
do you see anything no I can't help
thinking what these guys have bought
that loot yeah what do you think we got
alright there it is get ready let's get
the goods out of here
Lovett zero says should we take their
loot these guys yeah three of us and two
of them well we got 60 seconds I say we
do it Brian you game all right here
comes a sticky on my mark
college kids Oh Emma left there all
right I got her
running low on house
mission AJ I'm down I'm down can you
help them out I'm leading Zoey
fifteen seconds Brian what are you
waiting for do it clock's ticking let's
go
hostile agent neutralized
you know how I feel about this game I
loved it even when even when the build
wasn't finished yes when you weren't
supposed to play yeah it looks amazing
a huge dick move there at the end but um
I just I want to say I mean this is a
compliment this game is looking like it
needs to come with a giant barrel of
xanax yeah hi
maybe DLC yeah um what does everybody
else get to crap their selves in terror
the same way that I did when I played
the game last year on the floor well for
those of you lucky enough to be with us
here at e3 for the first time the
division is hands on playable at our
booth so hopefully everyone will come by
and play we're excited about that
awesome and also for those of you at
home we were clamoring to get your hands
on the game early we're happy to
announce that we're going to be having
betas like on Xbox one Playstation 4 and
PC starting early next year so everyone
we get to play it's gonna be super
exciting now
oh wait and please check that out to be
able to figure out get more information
about the betas suite now now that we
know the removing innovative Wednesday
I'm actually going to be available to
everybody out there to play by and put
into their home foxholes yes
today we're super happy to announce that
Tom Clancy's the division will be
released on March 8 2016 on all
platforms simultaneously yay Eric
reading infinite hop so thank you very
much everyone and have a great III by
Bernard everybody
I just I did get to play this game its
tactical it's terrifying
it's obviously incredibly cool so I
can't wave you guys to check it out on
the floor now next up this afternoon is
the newest release of the critically
acclaimed city builder from Ubisoft Blue
Byte studio so everybody pack up your
astronaut diapers because we are
departing this planet
you
hey Mike what's your ETA every burger
received 26 point one three three
degrees north three point six to eight
degrees nice got it
don't have no heart
how could you know that
107 heavy
except ahead of you
obviously the moon is awesome but you
don't actually get to start on the moon
you have to earn your lunar landing so
the following gameplay sequence shows
how you could make your own giant leap
for mankind' than if you want to test
out the game stay tuned for the beta
which starts later this year
so we've had samurai we've had
fire-breathing unicorns tallies
spaceships virus ridden dark zones this
has been a pretty mean friendly show
what do you think that's pretty awesome
you're actually sitting here and you are
your own human life-sized meme tell me
who you are
well I'm Rick from RBF productions and L
and you'll be self requested me here as
Jacob fried jacob frye from AC syndicate
right look insanely hot that's but a guy
from your era probably has rickets or
something I can catch but you look
amazing we should come up with a meme
really quickly for this show right now
I'm pitching who kept the Christmas
lights on during the apocalypse but
there's got to be and just captain
picard like screaming that out do you
have a me me one up you want to pitch Oh
guys with records are super hot well if
you're talking Picardo we'll be engaged
okay good we did that together alright
uh standing next to me right now my
friends is Jason Altman the executive
producer of our next game looking just
as foxy as Jacob fry with almost fewer
rickets
with 110 million players a billion songs
dance and more than a billion lifetime
views on YouTube this game franchise is
one of the pillars of the Ubisoft family
right it's time for Just Dance 2016
it is indeed thank you I'm gonna leave
it to you it's the fans that have made
your stance and success that it is and
because of them I'm really proud to say
that Just Dance has become the biggest
music video game franchise of all time
I gave him a spotlight so
now that we're into this tell me what
happens this Laster because this has
been amazing
we're back with Just Dance 2016 in all
motion platforms and I got a little bit
of news you don't need a camera
connected to your console to play the
game anymore you'll be able to use your
smartphone as a controller to play Just
Dance 2016 if you have a camera enabled
console you're good you're great but we
know many of you don't and we're excited
to be opening up the game to all console
owners regardless of their setup and
they're gonna have a lot to look forward
to an awesome tracklist a few kids new
features and like always a few surprises
like this one what
you
so honestly
I got Ali in the back of the cab
man
do you know what
I want to
and if you want
Oh
ah
and if you want me
people got me
just a kid I'm left to do
don't show
Oh
what you
yeah
we do
I want to win it
see anything in there
anyway
say Oh
ha
first of all I want to give you a huge
congratulations because your album
everything is four and the single want
to want me just hit number one on the
top 40 radio Drive this morning
number one congratulations and it was
amazing seeing up there you know I just
stay in my seat you know what I you know
I'm so glad this song is number one this
week and everything but the only thing
is I just wish you came up here and
dance with us in our cities is secondly
Jason I am living stumbling proof that
not all of our people can dance that's
just you know there's gotta be one I
missed that meeting but I wanna I want
to get into it cuz I actually heard that
you actually a big fan of his dance I am
a huge fan you know I love the idea that
you know music can inspire people but I
feel like this this video game is it's
such a part of pop culture and I feel
like it allows you know that the The
Young Ones like my little niece who
loves to play the game and you know the
folks like my mom who messes it doesn't
necessarily know how to dance but it
makes her feel like you know she could
get it inspires everybody nothing yeah
it's really great um I'm really excited
cuz this obviously this song is a huge
hit it's a number-one hit it's gonna be
in the game we're gonna want to buy that
when I dancing want to be like you can't
be Jason Derulo but you're gonna be like
Jason Derulo so thank you so much for
coming out today that was a big surprise
ladies and gentleman I'll see you
tomorrow
mwah give it up for Jason Derulo
everybody
so I said before I run backstage and try
to grab a selfie with Jason Derulo
you're gonna fight about that you will
one more thing to share just a it's 2016
will be available this October on all
platforms the Wii Xbox 360 ps3 but we
have something special for Wii U Xbox
one and ps4 players awesome
we're introducing a streaming service
that brings new songs all year long and
all the greatest hits have just danced
straight to your console it's something
the fans have been asking for for a long
time it's called just dance unlimited
and it's the first ever dance on-demand
streaming subscription service awesome
anyone with a copy of Just Dance 2016
that Wii U Xbox one or ps4 will be able
to subscribe that's killer
it's so great that's new fresh content
all the time so great thank you very
much sir
everybody made up for the other Jason Oh
Jay Jason Altman
with my pleasure
I called you here today because we face
dire circumstances our intelligence has
confirmed the existence of a new threat
that is unlike any we have seen before
this organization has the ability to
carry out attacks anywhere in the world
they are highly lethal an indiscriminate
of age religion or nationality the
potential for loss of human life and
psychological terror is substantial and
cannot be ignored
they are the very definition of an
unknown quantity hourly choice of action
is to meet force with force as of this
moment my program is reactivated and I
am handing over command of all global
field operation to you
recruit the operators from among the
world's foremost elite borders and
protocols are irrelevant
we must be the shield that safeguards
the civilized world from those who wish
to do it armed
no matter how or where our enemy strike
no matter what defense they cower behind
team rainbow must stand ready
now if you watched the conference last
year you know that I personally lost my
[ __ ]
when I saw Rainbow six siege I was so
excited I love this franchise judging
from the honest reaction I think we're
all having the same feeling about this
game it is close quarters combat like
you have never experienced before
everything is destructible and my
friends once you die you stay dead it's
explosive
it's bone-rattling it's intense and it's
led by an equally intense but cool
headed woman by the name of six you
probably recognized her in the cinematic
trailer and now it is my great honor to
welcome to the stage the extraordinary
Angela Bassett
how are you gorgeous oh my god alright I
I love this game I love this franchise
but now that you're in it I don't even
know I got I just so this is actually
the first time that you've been in a
video my first time yeah so tell me a
little about that that experience for
you oh well you know Thank You Ayesha
yeah I play the role of six and I'm the
deputy director of The Rainbow Six
counterterrorism unit it has been a
great experience so far and you know I'm
all about playing interesting characters
and this definitely was the venue for
that yeah I think actually people don't
realize how complex videogame acting can
be when I was in watchdogs my character
got pancaked by garbage truck so I'm
just happy to see that yours is a little
bit more later than Mike's managed to
avoid all that leads to my knowledge
right yeah well mostly she just guys the
Rainbow unit you know to make sure that
the operations has you know all of the
Intel that they need to be able to
eliminate threats right you've you I
mean as an actress it's incredible to be
here with you because you played
everyone Tina Turner dr. Betty Shabazz
Rosa Parks now Marie Laveau and American
Horror Story and watch Ben were there
any ways in which this work differed
from those other experiences for you
well I've always gravitated toward
characters that you know challenge me as
an actor so in that respect it wasn't
very much different and there was a lot
of you know stuff from a movie set a TV
set that was applicable to this you know
it's all about character and is all
about story you know and I was able to
really just take on the character and
make it my own and of course she had the
director who was there leading you cuz
your if you know they're alone so Ryan
wanted to make sure that the states were
heightened and you were exactly where
you needed to be and you know for those
gamers who are out there we're taking
taken command yeah what and it's an
immersive experience it's like living
through a film and with you in this film
we get to all play opposite you so I
know it's a dream come true for me I
can't wait to see what you've done with
it
ladies and gentlemen truly one of the
great actresses of our time please give
it up for Angela Bassett thank you
thank you give it up for Angela Bassett
everybody
all right so so far we've only been
talking about multiplayer but there is
so much more to see and hear tell us
more about it please welcome to the
stage Jenna vfo J the community
developer on Rainbow six siege thanks
Asia hi everyone
ever since we announced at e3 last year
the community has been asking about the
solo and co-op experiences of our game
today we are glad to announce that
Tarrant is back
it will be playable solo or with up to
four friends in terror hunt our players
will be facing the most challenging AI
in a Rainbow six game yet the terrorists
will be able to create a stronghold and
lead an assault using destruction in
unexpected ways so let's see it in
action our team's mission will be to
disarm bombs set in a French consulate
will be following team captain Chris
Henry over here throughout this demo
keep in mind that this is a live demo
and anything can happen we hope you
enjoy Chris are you ready yes just like
your team are you ready yeah yeah let's
do it have fun
hope you enjoy
alright guys let's do this yep Bruno
watch you start head to the right-hand
side with your team you have to stay
back for a second let's go to the left
hand side here yeah okay let me see
no there's nothing on the Left I got the
front door barricaded and looks like the
balcony up top two windows are
barricaded - okay I said we stick close
to running here let's move up yeah let's
go Gary sighs clear I see an opening on
the top floor through that window in the
corner there okay yeah let's step top
guys strike them at the east side wall
let me know if you see anybody inside
the window right yeah okay Bruno listen
to the Rope real quick - ready let's get
it out okay so we have two guys inside
we could probably take him out wisely
okay come up to the rooftop colonel I
guess clear on my side good yeah okay
I'm gonna be the hands here anybody have
a silencer on the other side I have a
silencer and I have visual okay you want
take them down and go three two one go
got it
good job a side right now take a look at
the back of the room make sure it's
clear it's clear okay let's set up here
for a second guys yep want to set my
drone out Scout before move Oh
look pretty good by the first bear k
that I don't see too much another pair
kid on the right here and I got a lot of
nitrous all set up just behind it I also
saw a Saab bomber here's a little always
you could consider drone out start
taking care of the drone the traffic
count in my chakra take care about yeah
bombers right there hold on hold on
so he starts going back right okay
you're good man he's coming back now I'm
safe dad you're good go for it
on the steppe movin up keep an eye on
the ball all right
I have one shoes here at the end of the
hallway I got a guy behind the desk the
cosmic office desk got one guy also by
the shield okay you guys ready move up
yeah yes we are go jab Nikko myself
you're gonna head down the main hallway
Gerudo Meg come over here tear down the
wall star coming down the left-hand side
going in I'll give you some cover
you got a shield right in front of you
hustle down bit come in clear the room
yep we're good yeah
clear okay any token you [ __ ] door in
front of us now anything for you you
guys ready yeah go for it don't Boise no
one moving forward okay good there's the
other private key the former is behind
the second one there gap yeah I'll let
you push up first all right okay
stay back a little bit I'm a conference
call me right there he's right there
right there
need help we're okay LIGO pick me up
here take this is worse okay thanks in
your heard enough
yeah pretty hurt the whole weeks pretty
open so take cover behind my shield here
okay we're going to struggle at the main
hall you guys will start moving up on
the left-hand side yeah take your time
couple of guys on the end here
I'm down forgot I got a girdle pick it
up you push forward this one downloading
okay scuttle it up throw mag comfortable
ball the right going hard do one more
okay I'm right behind you go for it go
for it push up push up yeah okay
take a look on the right you go yeah got
my back yeah I'm watching right
breaching the rooms clear clear
hold on equal screen the ranch right
click we're good they're both down yeah
yeah okay the other negative let's set
up here they point in the front door
check the hallway there
Maggie's if you're left there does a
wall yep you make a couple holes for me
there sir people come back stairs I'm
gonna drop the diffuser right behind you
yeah I got it covered
we gotta hold it for a minute and we got
this let's do this you're gonna protect
it better left behind you just okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna create an opening here
waiting room wait right now
don't set up don't get up
with the windows guys another one come
right behind you yeah let's take a
little bit the hallway no one coming
back stairs yeah welcome another 100 in
the hallway
charge Charcot together question coming
up
we're got it is calling you The Bachelor
goes back windows Marian diamond
discovered this okay okay okay I got two
nickels always back there
[ __ ] I got jobactive appointment back
here yeah come over to the future five
seconds
down and down nice what guy
I have a jogger now
well then guys you did it this time huh
all right thank you very much for this
what you just saw was one out of our
four Durant's modes that we'll have in
Rainbow six siege including Tara Hunt
classic for those of you who are here in
LA we invite you to come to our booth to
get a first hands-on experience of Tara
hunt as well as try our new PvP mode and
map and for everybody helps back at home
we got something for you as well we are
glad to announce that our beta starts on
September 24th
it will be available on all platforms
and you'll be able to play both PvP and
taro hunt thank you everyone so much and
have a great show to the VF og give it
up for the Rainbow six siege team for
that live demo um I actually watched
those guys play that rehearsal and they
lost so just so you know that's real
gameplay that's the first time I've seen
them win that's like oh I kind of want
em to lose again I first fell in love
with gaming I think like most old people
like me did Lloyd around in our case as
a kid my two best friends were named
defender and tempest I occasionally kick
it with Qbert these were beautiful
friendships based on a solid foundation
of quarters and well arcades are mostly
gone now that style of gameplay is alive
and well as evidenced by TrackMania
turbo this year TrackMania is finally
making the leap from pc to new gen
consoles and it's bringing its thriving
community of customizable maps along
with it
take a look
everybody please give it up for Tommy
Francois and Cole swallow hello everyone
well Jule that trailer was cut from
gameplay footage and track replay what
you see is what you get now let's put
our money where our mouth is and show
you the game I'll swap make yourself at
home and pick your favourite track we
all know that's one one seven the other
cars you see on screen are ghosts of the
best time now play
Oh
-
my wife
so out gold medal all right let's go bow
TrackMania turbo is pretty impressive
ten more tracks in stadium just for the
blue series four environments for
different gameplays five difficulty
levels a total of 200 tracks and if you
think that's not enough take a look at
this magic our track builder mode
generates levels on the fly at the press
of one button it's random so we have no
idea what we're going to drive three
steps to it terraforming look at the
pretty beaches and Islands then the
track being built and finally signage
infinite tracks you can immediately play
let's see how well you do false well I'd
be careful that's tricky
easier to win an Academy Award in
playing live 83 man yeah funny huh
restart is immediate go
Hey
by the way this is a completely new
environment especially made for
TrackMania turbo
it's called roller coaster lagoon we
also have a brand new take on
multiplayer roads but for that Kumbi
times on the arcade machines on the
booth and if you're crazy enough can
play the VR demo at the show thank you
alligator de mas danke Shoen shochet
gracias now see spasiba all right give
it up for Tommy and Francois clearly
multilingual our next game has it all a
globe yeah yes I understand our next
game has it all a global conspiracy
multiple covert murders and leaps from
unreasonable Heights with absolutely no
physical repercussion whatsoever shine
up your blades and lace up your Greaves
this is Assassin's Creed syndicate
ah he got the message
let's travel out of my clothes come on
hurry up the fun never stops come on
look lively rooks
the
who the hell are you
oh why white away excited for me relax
try the pizza whose it is actually quite
drinkable go on toast your noble BOTS
fief of children or you could do better
join me join the rooks
okay
changeup mr. fry listen we just split
the money I mean just take your life
works with me going with a rock ball
come on soon enough
hello everybody thank you my name is
knuck exc Cote and I'm the creative
director on Assassin's Creed syndicate
our game takes place in London in 1868
right in the middle of the Industrial
Revolution this pivotal moment in
humanity's history has allowed us to
create the first modern Assassin's Creed
game together with their Street gang our
two Assassin's the twins Jacob and Evie
Frye will fight to take London out of
the hands of the greeting the corrupt in
order to give the city back to its
people we have a brand new gameplay demo
to show you at the Ubisoft booth but
this year we are letting you play the
game here at e3 and on console if you're
not one of the lucky few to be able to
make it to the ubisoft booth well we're
excited to give our fans the chance to
play a game at the you play lounge here
in LA and get this in 7 cities across
europe and australia so
so if you want to start playing
Assassin's Creed syndicate starting
tomorrow
just sign up at Assassin's Creed comm
for your chance to take back London
thank you and have a great a three in a
nice alright that my friends was awesome
incredible PC in that game that year as
I'm able experience out on the floor and
around the world and I think that's
pretty much it up except for this one
last thing everybody put them together
one more time for Ubisoft CEO Eve
Guillermo
we like to surprise you with new ideas
but really we really like to surprise
you with revolutionizing our beloved
franchises and this has been done by a
group in Paris a very good group that is
working in secrecy and he has been able
to create some things and I'm sure you
will enjoy because it is so good so have
a look
most of us fear death but for the center
blank and drug cartel death is a saint
they embrace her praise her worshipper
they kill thousands without
repercussions trafficking poison across
South America corroding governments how
do you fight an enemy that doesn't fear
death maybe you want them from the
clouds
down with the victory without knocking
him down just a female volley round the
beans
your heart is beating cuz you know that
position they loading up the cookie got
eyes on white hat okay
our job
or you fight from the shadows the tack
when they least expect make them apart
leave no evidence behind
laughs Matt o'clock
what editing tried
poor place
or you can unleash chaos strike from
every side confuse them destroy
everything decide who lives and who dies
groaning please
the lines must go
the boat Whitehead is a dead man walking
how do you fight an enemy that doesn't
fear death
you manipulate them from the inside
until the monsters wipe each other out
with the next target
this is the kind of insane immersive
cinematic open-world gameplay that you
come to Ubisoft for I know you felt that
all in your bones
ladies gentlemen that is our show thank
you so much for coming out today thanks
to everybody watching at home stay tuned
for the lightpost show we're going to
chat with all today's speakers if you're
in Los Angeles check out our booth and
you play loud to see Ghost Recon in
action and if you're not in LA check out
Ubisoft comm for exclusive III insider
access be sure to join our social media
conversation by using the hashtag UB e3
we want to hear from you and we mean it
no matter how painful or crappy your
tweets my name is Aisha Tyler
this is Ubisoft play on
you
alright that was the Ubisoft press
conference right here at e3 2015
let's start talking about what we saw
right at the end it looks like Ghost
Recon is back for the first time in a
long time since Advanced Warfighter 2
with Ghost Recon wildlands go ahead
Ghost Recon you know on online yes
peaches old libs yeah oh yeah future
soldiers love it oh it's had a few
actually my apologies
yeah what do you think about Weiland's
from what we saw it's from just fresh
off so this is their just cause II we
were we were saying while we were
watching it looked a bit spark right um
it had like a touch of watchdogs with
the yeah and the very idea I'm saying
quite quite is almost like mercenaries
co-op caveny a little bit yeah it was
very explodey yeah in that sense so we
know so far I guess is that this is an
open-world co-op game but with specific
missions as well yeah this drug lab set
up here was what they've sort of focused
on um Alexa any thoughts on what we've
seen here in terms of like what this
might be in terms of a grander game
because all they're showing here I guess
is a bunch of dudes going in to shoot a
bunch of other dudes like how do you how
do you think this looks differently to
other yeah Ubisoft shooters ah I don't
think it does like I'm seeing Far Cry
I'm seeing um like some watchdog
elements I think it's sort of an amalgam
of everything that they've been
exploring with other with other
franchises I mean that can work that's
super cool when they got to this part I
started thinking it might have been
khaliv Juarez yeah yeah there's a couple
of people on Twitter saying the same
thing as well Lucio your impressions it
is I think first of all got to celebrate
the fact that this was a genuine
surprise yeah true i mean they've kept
this really under wraps Anubis often not
really known for keeping the ship this
ship watertight um so I'm kind of yeah
I'm excited to see more of it it was
weird though I expected more of a
fanfare it is a new game um but we just
got this trailer um
so I'm excited about seeing it I assume
they're gonna have at least this trailer
or some representative on the booth to
talk about it yeah you'd hope so
um it looks cool I'm also card ah woman
yeah boom Roman good point that
technology spread across all of you
various teams and it's kind of an
itching to take I think
Kevin I'm kind of I like the fact that
this is I don't know the the co-op stuff
in Far Cry 4 was good fun the idea of
expanding that ed almost like the crew
where you've got this mad open world you
can team up with a couple of buddies and
I don't take on missions all around the
place I'm pretty excited but yeah I mean
I think it's gonna be super fun I mean I
think the downside of course is it does
remind us of all of the other Ubisoft
games yeah we looked at it and think hey
it looks like is this could this be Far
Cry maybe um and I think that's the only
the only real drawback at the the
specific might have been a surprise but
what this game is I don't think is
actually a surprise at all yeah whether
that doesn't mean it's not going to be
awesome or fun but I don't think that it
makes for much of a surprise yeah it's
crazy to think like how far removed this
is from the original title of Ghost
Recon as well it's kind of it's it the
things they've done with this franchise
have been kind of all over the place a
head tattoo yeah the head said that
might be my next sell to don't matter
you never know crosses tattooed on their
face I feel like that's something all of
our mothers who told us at some stage
you're not and that's Ghost Recon
wildlands that's all we know about it so
far that's our initial and imprint we
literally saw on like three minutes ago
yeah as your fingers crossed to be more
information about that and we'll have it
right here on GameSpot calm all right
next up to talk about we've got a bunch
of games to get through here folks and I
want to talk about the division next
we've seen the division at Ubisoft
conference a couple years in a row here
this is the third year they've had a big
fanfare Ronda is it just me or does this
game look not really as pretty as it did
a couple of years are you going down the
watchdog's room I don't say like this
downgrade nonsense but like man like the
dip Ghost Recon trailer looked better
than what I saw from the division well
we'll come back to that in two years
time oh yeah I don't know it's I'm happy
about today's gameplay because it
finally showed off the sort of online
connect ability what it means to be
playing this game with a bunch of people
and running into other people yeah not
also that Ryan guy God at the end of the
demo so I mean the other thing is I mean
we've seen a lot of these multiplayer
play throughs on the press conferences
but no one's really acting like they
would in a real multiplay situation
apart from that guy griefs everyone at
the end so what we saw in the demo was
the the the sort of the main human team
here we're following three characters
going around basically doing a mission
in the in the world of the division get
accosted by this other group of bad
online players and then they sort of
band together and then at the end they
decide to turn on them and then on the
end it turns out the one of their
friends decided to turn on them as well
so they really lose interesting to me I
mean other games of a Kane and Lynch is
the first game that comes to mind that's
done this before but what's interesting
about that is in Kane and Lynch had
always just devolved into everybody's
just going to betray everybody else in
whatever and so my Mike my first
question would be what's to keep that
from being a thing that you do what
thinking that you know it sounds like a
good idea but in practice is it really
going to be meaningful or is it always
just going to end up being the same
anyway yeah I'm really curious about
that yeah it's got good to see them show
off a little bit more of the
connectability stuff but still it's it's
almost a thing we're so intrigued by
that there are as many questions that
get answered we get loads more questions
like for instance why do you leave a
Christmas tree lit up when electricity
seems to have gone out in most of the
city because you know the spirit of
Christmas lives on done because
sometimes you need a good shot and
sometimes the shot overrides logic in
film and in games the point and see this
is the crow essential moment where he's
like no I'm not gonna help you up bro is
you off because this is Internet video
games look God look at the numbers guns
them down yes their stuff kind of just
looks at him stares him in the eye lo
but we also got a date for the division
and March 8 2016 so we can look forward
to not slipping probably one more time
before cynics all of us cynics I'm
really excited for the division I like
it on paper I like the the idea of the
interconnected multiplayer the idea of
being in groups I'm a little bit down on
the graphic stuff final thoughts on the
division Alexa what do you think I don't
know I am sort of I feel like there are
so many military shooters or military
ask shooter yeah newbie stop speaking
all of
yeah I don't know I some still die still
don't think I've seen anything different
other than I guess the ability to turn
on your team
yeah and take their stuff nobody think
was you know I could've like I like the
idea um it kinda reminded me a little
bit of I'm alive you Besson ya fabled
other post-apocalyptic Game Boy I just
had that kind of feeling you know when
the two groups kind of came up against
each other and you're like - I trust him
do I not my mail didn't matter yeah I
mean that game could have been so much
so much more but maybe some of the ideas
went into a division I don't know my
looks I'd I'm still cautious than too
excited mm yeah Kevin final thoughts
yeah it's still same pretty much
cautiously optimistic about it perhaps
because I want the destiny asked to be a
burgeoning genre of its own that's
worthy of getting attention and this is
the one game right now that seems to be
really following in those footsteps and
I really want a better type of destiny
game so maybe this will be it maybe not
maybe 2016 is the year of that sort of
maybe there's more and more of these
games at coming after ya destiny -
coming to e3 2016 what we've been
playing at the division by the time that
comes out March 8th 2016 is when
hopefully as long as doesn't slip we'll
all be playing the division and if you
want any updates on that game of course
stay tuned right here to GameSpot calm
all right we got a bunch more games to
talk about how about Assassin's Creed
syndicate we saw some more Assassin's
Creed syndicate snow we didn't know so a
season trailer we saw CGI trailer which
which looks almost as close to gameplay
that I feel like I'm being cheated when
I watch it because it kind of looks like
a comedy right that good but it doesn't
and Kevin what are your thoughts on
sendagaya I'm sort of iffy at this point
just because they oh they always know
how to pick a good song for a trailer so
plus they're um but it's it's just a
Sasson Creed and I can't believe I've
got this thing on my arm and I'll sign
this hey know those flames are real good
they were but I don't know like I'm at
the stage where I'm just like I needed
to see more
there was nothing more of Assassin's
Creed I mean they're all there'll be
more at the show clearly that'll be
playable and that kind of thing I think
but I don't know just that in and of
itself Plus this is really nitpicky
but as somebody who's played so much
Assassin's Creed the lighting and the
colors are sort of bothering me yeah
because the trailer sort of had some of
the same that the yellow has just been
cranked up so high good lighting and
dissipated driving me insane and we saw
that in the the gameplay footage that
they also showed that the yellow has
been cranked up so high it's like I find
it much better obviously because it's CG
but just even in terms of the style I
just preferred this so much better
something about the lighting and the
gameplay we've seen that really irks me
and I just there's all of this could
look s-- close enough to gameplay yeah
it's just a little bit jarring I mean if
you're gonna kill some horses you might
as well do god I hated this and at least
they might as well be English yeah I
mean what good is an interface marriage
to that car equine leap of faith yeah
yeah this is a renowned for being really
able to take full take a fall on the
face
Aleksey we're looking forward to seeing
the other protagonist of this trailer as
well and they didn't do it no I'm
disappointed because we've seen two bits
of gameplay and trailers now and there
they keep saying oh this is gate this
game is about jacob and evie frye and
they talk about the twins and how
they're both important but we now have
two very lengthy cgi trailers just focus
focusing on this male protagonist and
it's doubly disappointing because it
Bethesda yesterday we got two trailers
with that you can play as a man or women
and they had the dishonored your the
option to play is either and they chose
to focus on Emily I wonder if this is
their PR team deciding that they're
going to leave all that stuff till the
last yeah her just for six months
showing him off last six months showing
her off we'll have to wait and see but
it did seem a little bit weird because
they've been teasing her for so long to
then spend six minutes showing off this
dude again the way he just looks like a
British Ezio kind of a jerk
facial hair looks dumb yeah beloved
alright I guess I'll have to wait and
see any other thoughts on on this Bubba
Lucy you know I mean we're gonna be
seeing it on the GameSpot stage actually
check out where we're gonna have
hopefully actual gameplay so I'm excited
to see that so I mean yeah it's
Assassin's Creed I'll play it I know I
will
there's no point saying that I won't I
want to get real excited for Assassin's
Creed game I know right right yeah like
I don't I think all four of us are
people who enjoy Sasa's Creed
but it's just yeah it's not happy hyped
up right now about half this hard and
that's coming at this calendar year so
fingers crossed we'll see some more and
fingers crossed we'll have some more
coverage as well in the GameSpot stage
so make sure you stay tuned to case
welcome for more of that all right let's
do a quick little roundup of everything
else we saw first off TrackMania turbo
no one expected that oh and Zopa if you
like trackmania yeah you know it like it
looked fun anything they said they had a
VR demo yes good thing I'll actually get
sick on V or I feel like that might be
the quickest way to get sick on viewer I
just need to vomit yeah yeah oh god just
thinking of it now makes me think oh my
god I was it was a game called toy box
turbos which very similar premise and
they did it in VR but they did it you
know the camera pulled way back and kind
of following along and that didn't kind
of work created that was good going from
third person to first person and there
you move it around so fast this really
looks like trackmania nations which was
a Kabul live it's about maybe four years
old going there before all that maybe a
planet nonsense so we don't know if
they're actually going to keep with
ManiaPlanet that was when they released
TrackMania and they had like you did you
got like or you get to buy stadium and
you to buy all your different like areas
and this one they say there's going to
be four environments off the track 200
tracks they also have their sort of
procedurally generated track thing as
well variety of cars as well it's kind
of like f1 v8 looking things there and
some other type of dirt cars yeah and
also virtual reality they go and a
bitchin hat yeah sweet yep truck man
ease back in a big way and for a second
it also looked like we had some sort of
my god [ __ ] what was that like I
can't on it every McGeorge siders it's
dark setters and it's a cat riding a
fire-breathing unicorn the double
rainbow in the background like oh of
course it's Charles few trials fusions
expansion back yeah god it was like his
ride so this is like the Blood Dragon
for trials right yeah child and this an
expansion pack were you what is your
caste riding a unicorn with everything
with your also funny is so fun mo edgy
welcome to the future and then Ramos
thing is no no just let this speak for
itself yeah no triple rainbow there's a
whole bunch of knots is gonna this is
awesome level max which is the expansion
coming soon for phatso transfusion add
there was new add-on game is an allure I
know to widget to 205 oh yeah so what
was last 120 70 70 yeah so they're going
to mature again on future again you
decided with a moon I did play this is
that I can't get into specifics until
tomorrow but we know that it exists now
and so yeah the moon and it's a city
builder and there's a whole I mean if
you've played the anima series where you
sort of know what you're getting into
and so you know a trade game you know a
game where you build city and you're
trading to make your citizens more and
more happy and to expand and stuff like
that but with the moon yeah I'm I guess
to be more on that on game spas tomorrow
Kevin yeah totally sweet and moving
swiftly on who knew they had some
dancing happening JC hello just turned
up that was like do you remember when I
sure paid the Microsoft press conference
I forget there he is
there it is do it so I'm singing yeah
whatever you're no Prince Jason and this
is coming in on a bunch of platforms
they're also bringing it just dance
unlimited on ps4 Xbox one Wii U I think
they also have them they also said you
can play with your phone now great when
she said that last year yeah don't even
need a console Johnny well the best is
deployed to dance with my phone
yeah when people look at me while I'm
dancing looking at my phone um paint a
falling beam while they're dancing um I
mean I mean listening like there's not
much you can say about just dancing yeah
yeah this is the game which you dance
now let's stretch let's keep going let's
keep going five minutes I'm just OH
hundred fifty of the greatest just dance
hits new songs all of them Gangnam style
alright recommend always yeah oh good
but I think the best presentation I know
we like to Jason dilute your brood a
little how about an actual Viking coming
out on stage oh it's like a game that
guy for honor that looks awesome beard
guy is the best guy that ever guide in
the history know you're a fan of a beard
guy yeah the beard guy was the best guy
and he is the Dark Lord
yes on Twitter the underscore Dark Lord
Lord with an e I'd like to point out so
he's the underscore Dark Lord II so you
should follow this dude because he's
frightening and great kimbugs bad beard
guy evangelist whether you think of for
honor I want that combat in Assassin's
Creed why can't we have that kind of
like Shiva it looks like chivalry but
does it have MOBA elements cuz it looked
like there was stuff going on in the
background like maybe this is yeah like
I was kind of thinking do i rear Ephrata
does MOBA like titanfall those done we
don't say that's a MOBA oh yeah well I
mean I don't know it's hard to tell hmm
I thought maybe there were creeps and
there were like you know like territory
to control I guess you move further
towards the yeah the enemy camp but I
don't know I could be just making the
[ __ ] up so I go looks wrong that's kind
of what I'm doing actually I'm at the
last games talk about South Park the
fractured bought hole Oh what you are
naming the hole they really want a 9.5
on games I don't have the heart to tell
them we don't even have 9.5 s anymore
but I'll go with it go with it Trey and
mash back on stage doing it again this
time obsidian not involved Ubisoft San
Francisco apparently ah not really a
surprise yeah I'm not surprised either
why obsidian isn't is it isn't is a good
good developer but they do other things
hmmm I think better than what they did
with with southpark okay yeah I loved
stick of truth but I thought it was a
little too like formal or simple it was
a little too formulaic and it was simple
real easy fibrin and hilarious and
awesome and there was so much more to do
with it um I liked the game but I think
that maybe that maybe this is an
opportunity for Ubisoft uh stuff to
really push the boundaries there well I
also think obsidian moves to new things
pretty quickly they don't really stick
with something well that's all that you
be soft hot to show for us we're gonna
take a quick little break and we will be
back right here on the game spot I guess
war room stage Sony's kicking off in
just a little bit of times are going to
start our pre-show for that so stay
tuned and we'll be back girl would
you